BRITTA DEGROOT: My
name is Britta DeGroot.
And I'm a junior, studying
music with a concentration
in piano performance.
It is an honor and a pleasure to
introduce the speaker tonight.
John Steele Gordon was
educated at Millbrook School
and Vanderbilt University.
His articles have appeared
in numerous publications,
including Forbes, National
Review, Commentary,
The New York Times, The
Wall Street Journal.
He is the contributing
editor at American Heritage,
where he wrote the
"Business of America"
column for many years and
currently writes "The Long
View" column for Barron's.
He is the author
of several books,
including Hamilton's Blessing,
The Extraordinary Life
and Times of Our National Debt;
The Great Game, the Emergence
of Wall Street as a World
Power; The Business of America;
Tales from the Marketplace,
American Enterprise
from the Settling of New
England to the Breakup of AT&T;
and An Empire of Wealth,
the Epic History of American
Economic Power.
Please join me in welcoming
Mr. Gordon to the podium.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
Good evening.
I am both happy and honored to
be back at Hillsdale College
once again.
I'm here to talk about Socialism
in American history, which
is to say the history of
Socialism on very stony ground.
Socialism is, by definition,
an economic system
wherein the means of production
are held in common, that is,
by the government.
Socialism, therefore,
necessarily concentrates power,
for while the people
might, in theory, own
the means of production, only
individuals can actually act.
So Socialism in
all its many forms,
from the Democratic Socialism
of post-World War II Britain,
to the unspeakable horrors
of Pol Pot's Cambodia,
to that weird combination,
a Communist monarchy
in North Korea, means not only
economic power to the people
but economic power
to fiduciaries
for the people, the same people
who exercise political power.
And as Lord Acton
famously noted,
"Power corrupts, and absolute
power corrupts absolutely."
That's why, in
capitalist countries,
the rich become powerful.
In Socialist ones, the
powerful become rich.
[LAUGHTER]
In a Socialist economy,
one is expected
to work for the common interest,
not one's own interest.
But that's not
easy to accomplish.
For self-interest is,
in the living universe,
a force as all pervasive
and ineluctable as gravity
is in the physical one.
By having the
means of production
in the hands of individuals
and corporations,
capitalism both
disperses power and takes
advantage of self-interest.
In other words, capitalism
swims downstream.
For Socialism to work, it has
to somehow negate self-interest.
It has to swim upstream.
To use the analogy of gravity
again, we can negate gravity.
That's how we got to
the moon 50 years ago
and how I got to Hillsdale
College this morning.
[LAUGHTER]
But it takes energy to do so.
This is why Socialist economies,
even on a very small scale,
have only worked for any length
of time by the use of coercion.
That's why the phrase
"democratic Socialism,"
a phrase much in vogue these
days, is largely an oxymoron.
Now, we usually think
of the United States
as the most capitalist
of all major countries,
and it mostly is.
While it may have been pure
coincidence that the United
States was born the very same
year that Adam Smith published
The Wealth of Nations, it
was a most fortuitous one.
Alexander Hamilton, who richly
deserves the title Founding
Father of the American
Economy, was very familiar
with Smith's seminal
book, as were
most of the Founding Fathers.
Hamilton took its arguments
very much to heart.
When Socialism was
rapidly evolving
into a coherent philosophy
3/4 of a century later,
Karl Marx wrote in The 18th
Brumaire of Louis Bonaparte,
published in 1852, after
Napoleon III had seized power
in a coup d'etat, that, quote,
"Men make their own history,
but they do not make
it as they please.
They do not make it
under circumstances
chosen by themselves,
but under circumstances
directly encountered and
transmitted from the past."
But this country, unlike
the European countries
Marx was familiar
with, had, in fact,
precious little past to
be transmitted in 1776.
We were not a
fully-formed society
with deeply entrenched
economic interests
and a well-developed
class system.
In effect, we were something
like a national tabula
rasa in the 1780s and '90s.
So more than almost any
other country in history,
the United States could
make itself as it pleased,
in ways that deeply suited
the American character.
It is worth noting
that all but one
of the 10 amendments
to the Constitution,
known as the Bill of
Rights, protect individuals
from excessive government power.
It is this character,
this passion
to do as we damn well please
under the rule of law,
that has made this country such
stony ground for Socialism.
Now, the American
colonies benefited greatly
from the mother
country's benign neglect.
Unlike France and
Spain, England didn't
care who went to its
colonies and, indeed,
used the colonies as a dumping
ground for convicted felons.
It was Britain's inability to
continue transporting felons
to America after the American
Revolution that led directly
to the settlement of
Australia in 1788.
Perhaps they should
celebrate July 4th, too.
[LAUGHTER]
That meant that the
population of early America
was largely made
up of people who
marched to the beat
of a distant drummer.
Unlike their contemporaries
in the poor economy
of early 17th
century Britain, they
chose to take an
enormous chance.
They said goodbye to all that
they had known and came to,
what one Puritan called a
"howling wilderness," in hopes
of making better
and more prosperous
lives for themselves
and their posterity.
As to how big a chance they
were taking, consider this.
In early Virginia,
the death rate
for immigrants in their
first year was about 25%.
After that, they were
said to be seasoned,
and their life expectancy
increased considerably.
And these risk-taking
immigrants, of course,
have been coming ever since.
Thus, the propensity
for taking risk
was bred into the very
DNA of this country.
And the twin engines
of capitalist success
or a willingness to take
risk and competition,
neither of which are found
in Socialist economies, which
is why they are both
un-innovative and poor.
Even the DNA of those
felonious transportees,
a total of about 100,000
during the Colonial era,
added a certain je ne sais quoi
to the American genetic mix.
That is not to say that
this country has had
no experience with Socialism.
Indeed, the early English
settlements in this country
were, at first,
Socialist enterprises,
even though the
very word Socialism
wouldn't be coined until 1833.
The colony of Virginia
was not established
by the English government.
Instead, it was founded by
a profit-seeking corporation
chartered by King
James I in 1606,
the Virginia Company of London.
The stock was mostly owned by
very wealthy London merchants.
These were very
savvy businessmen.
But the company they founded
was in a wholly new business,
American plantations.
And the steep learning
curve to profitability
that any new type of
business necessarily entails
would not be successfully
climbed in this case.
The Virginia Company invested
all told about 50,000 pounds
sterling in the
enterprise, a colossal sum
in the early 17th century,
when the annual Crown
revenues from the
tariff amounted
to only about 75,000 pounds.
Regardless, the company
had collapsed by 1624,
and Virginia became
a Crown colony.
Indeed, the Virginia Company
made just about every mistake
that it could have made.
Jamestown was sited
badly, surrounded
by mosquito-breeding
swamps, and where
the water was often brackish.
This led to salt poisoning
during the hot humid Virginia
summers.
But the Virginia
Company's biggest mistake
was to keep title to the
land, the means of production.
The settlers were,
in effect, to work it
as peasants for the
company's profit.
But the company also told
them that any gold they found
was theirs to keep or sell.
The settlers that the
Company had recruited,
all men in the first year
or so, another mistake,
were mostly what were then
called "sturdy beggars,"
i.e., healthy men
who had no employment
and had gravitated to the
burgeoning slums of London
and Bristol along
with the younger
sons of gentry families.
The first group knew
little about farming,
and the latter was
disinclined to do hard work.
Pursuing their self-interest,
as people always do,
they preferred to search
for gold from which
they could profit directly.
Of course, there
is no gold to be
found in the broad alluvial
plains of tidewater Virginia,
although they found
plenty of a form of mica
that looked a bit like gold.
They shipped it to England where
it was found to be worthless.
The result was starvation.
Of the 104 settlers who had
arrived in May, 1607, only 38
were still alive
nine months later.
In December, 1609, the
colony had 220 settlers.
By spring, 1610, only
60 were still alive.
One man, crazed by hunger,
had killed and eaten his wife.
He was burned at the stake.
The company tried other
means to generate income.
They established a glass
factory, for instance,
to take advantage of Virginia's
abundant sand and wood.
But the glass could not be
profitably exported to England.
Two developments
saved the colony.
One was the discovery
of a cash crop, tobacco.
After the Indians had told
the colonists the exacting
art of growing and curing it,
tobacco became very profitable
indeed.
The second was the abandonment
of the company's policy
of holding title to the
land and expecting colonists
to work it as sharecroppers.
Indeed, the company began to
use early America's greatest
resource, its infinity of
land, to entice settlers.
They started to give every
settler, who had paid
his own way, 50 acres
of land, along with 50
acres for each relative and
servant brought to the colony.
Thus, a family of five
would get 250 acres of land.
That much good agricultural
land in land-poor England
would have given that
family gentry status.
It was a powerful and
thoroughly capitalist incentive.
Those who would come
as indentured servants
were also given land once they
had served their indentures.
Food production rose sharply,
and tobacco production
soared, from 20,000
pounds in 1618 to 1
and 1/2 million pounds
only 11 years later.
The American experiment
was off and running,
and Virginia's early
Socialist economy forgotten.
Early New England,
which was also
settled by profit-seeking
joint stock companies,
saw the land held
in common, as well,
and thus saw poor results.
In the Plymouth Colony,
despite the story
of the first Thanksgiving, the
harvest of 1621 had been poor.
In early 1622, Governor
William Bradford
gave each family a plot of land.
But he required that, quote,
"All profits and benefits that
are not got by trade, working,
fishing, or any other means,
were to be placed in a common
storehouse, so that," quote,
"all such persons as
are of this colony
are to have their meat, drink,
apparel, and all provisions out
of the common stock."
In other words,
the settlers were
expected to work the fields,
to go out fishing and hunting,
but the results were to be
doled out to each family,
according to its
size, not according
to its contribution of labor.
The result was a very
poor harvest in 1622
and severe hunger in the
winter of 1622 through '23.
But Bradford, happily,
was no ideologue.
He could learn from experience.
He wrote in his book, A
Plymouth Plantation, quote,
"The failure of that
experiment of communal service,
the taking away of
private property,
and the possession
of it in community
by a commonwealth was found
to breed much confusion
and discontent and retard
much employment, which
would have been to
the general benefit,
for the young men who were
most able and fit for service
objected to being forced
to spend their time
and strength in working for
other men's wives and children
without any recompense."
The strong man or
the resourceful man
had no more share of
food, clothes, et cetera,
than the weak man, who was not
able to do a quarter of what
the other could.
This was thought injustice.
The aged and graver men, who
were ranked and equalized
in labor, food,
clothing, et cetera,
with the humbler
and younger ones,
thought it was some indignity
and disrespect to them.
Bradford decided that each
family could grow and keep
the food they raised.
The change in attitude among
the settlers was stunning.
The women in 1622 had stayed
home to tend the children.
But in 1623, as Bradford
explained, quote,
"The women now went
willingly into the field
and took their little ones
with them to set corn."
Food production
rose dramatically.
Within a couple of
years, the colony
was able to export a
load of grain to England.
As the historian
Nathaniel Philbrick
explained in his recent history
of Plymouth Colony, quote,
"The pilgrims had stumbled
on the power of capitalism."
Although the fortunes
of the colony
still teetered precariously
in the years ahead,
the inhabitants
never again starved.
Of course, New
England early turned
to trading and shipbuilding,
given the lack of a cash crop
in New England's stony
soil and long winters.
And those early merchants
knew all about capitalism,
even though the word wouldn't
be invented for another couple
of hundred years.
Indeed, many of them wrote
at the tops of their ledgers,
"In the name of God and
profit," for these pious Puritan
merchants saw a personal
economic success
as a sign of God's grace.
It'd be nice if Elizabeth
Warren had the same attitude.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Now, among the early
settlers of Colonial America
were many groups seeking
religious freedom.
And the United States
remains the most religious
of Western nations.
This yearning for moral
and spiritual perfection,
so much a part of the
American character,
has led to a plethora of new
American-born religious sects,
such as the Church of Jesus
Christ of Latter-days, Seventh
Day Adventists, the Shakers,
Jehovah's Witnesses,
and Christian Science,
to name just a few
of the more successful
and long-lived.
But it also led to
many social experiments
in a search for a
new way of living,
where property was
to be held in common.
The most famous
of these projects
was New Harmony, Indiana.
It was founded in 1825 by a
wealthy British industrialist
named Robert Owen, who
was one of the founders
of the movement that came to
be called Utopian Socialism.
It got that name, by the
way, because the founders
of the movement believed that
Socialism could be achieved
without class struggle
but rather by example,
to demonstrate that
society could work
in a different and better way.
And as with Ralph Waldo
Emerson's "better mousetrap,"
the world would beat
a path to your door.
Marx and Engels dismissed this
as utopian, and the term stuck.
Marx and Engels, for
once, were right.
Owen put his money
where his mouth was.
In 1825, he bought an
entire town, 20,000 acres,
in the southwest
corner of Indiana,
plus the buildings
and infrastructure
from a German religious sect
that had decided to relocate.
He paid $150,000, a
very substantial fortune
in the 1820s.
People were expected to provide
their own household goods,
to invest their
capital in enterprises
that would promote
community independence
and social equality.
They would work
for the community
and be paid in credits
at the town's store,
or they could buy credits there.
There were troubles
from the beginning.
There was a shortage
of skilled craftsmen,
and the community could
not produce enough goods
to pay its way.
Robert Dale Owen,
son of the founder,
described the people who
settled in New Harmony, quote,
as "a heterogeneous
collection of radicals,
enthusiastic devotees
to principle,
honest latitudinarians,
and lazy theorists,
with a sprinkling of
unprincipled sharpers thrown
in."
As to the town's prospects,
he wrote that, quote,
"a plan which
remunerates all alike
will, in the present
condition of society,
ultimately eliminate from
a cooperative association
the skilled, efficient, and
industrious members, leaving
an ineffective and sluggish
residue, in whose hands
the experiment will fail, both
socially and pecuniarily."
In other words, self-interest
dooms such enterprises.
The New Harmony experiment had
collapsed within two years,
and private property
and individual pursuit
came to the town.
Now, there have been dozens, if
not hundreds, of other attempts
to establish
Socialist communities,
but most have failed,
although there
is one in Virginia on 400
acres of what was once
a tobacco farm that has
been in operation for more
than 50 years.
After the Civil War, as
the country industrialized
at a furious pace,
the wealth inequality
increased at an
equally furious pace.
Enormous fortunes epitomized
by the 400 New York
families invited to
Mrs. Astor's annual ball
were piled up, while
industrial workers did not
get anything like a fair
share of the profits they
helped create.
The reason, of course, was that
each big industrial corporation
spoke with one voice,
while there were often
tens of thousands of workers,
each spoke for himself.
Now industrial capitalism
was something very new
under the sun in the
late 19th century.
And the rules needed to make
it function fairly and well
could only be developed
from experience.
The stock market reforms
of the post Civil War era,
the invention of
independent accountants
and generally-accepted
accounting principles
in the 1890s, the Sherman and
Clayton Anti-trust legislation
of 1890 and 1914, the creation
of the Interstate Commerce
Commission in 1887, and
the Wagner Act of 1939
were what resulted.
It was a process that
would take about 50 years.
And, of course, the reforms
have needed their own reforms
over the years.
The Interstate Commerce
Commission, for instance,
was meant as a check on the
unbridled economic power
of railroads.
But it quickly
evolved into a cartel,
protecting the
railroads' profits
and greatly inhibiting
innovation in that industry.
When its rate-setting powers
were abolished in the 1970s,
so that railroads and trucking
firms could once again compete
by means of price, the
transportation sector
of the GDP dropped
from 15% to 10%.
As transportation is what
economists call a transaction
cost, a necessary
cost that does not
increase the value
of the product,
the prices of
millions of products
dropped as competition
forced manufacturers
to share the lower costs of
transportation with consumers.
It should be noted that
we are, today, beginning
to learn what rules are
needed to properly regulate
the new digital
economy we now live
in that has caused another
surge in income inequality.
Meanwhile, there
were increased calls
for Socialism in
American politics
as a way to abate this
increasing inequality,
just as there are today.
Among the leaders
of this movement
was Eugene V. Debs, born in
1855 in Terre Haute, Indiana.
He came from a
middle class family.
His father owned a
small textile business.
But he dropped out of school at
the age of 14 and went to work
for a local railroad
earning $0.50 a day.
He quickly identified
with the working class
and its economic problems
in the new Industrial Age.
Debs was a founder of
an early labor union,
the Industrial
Workers of the World--
remembered as the Wobblies--
as well as the
American Railway Union.
The Pullman Strike
of 1894, led by Debs
after an initial
hesitation, was one
of a series of often violent
strikes at this time.
The Pullman Strike resulted
in about $80 million
worth of damage and 13 deaths.
Charged with contempt
of court for violating
a federal injunction
against the strike,
he served six months in jail.
During that time,
Debs read widely
about international Socialism
and emerged from jail
a firm believer in it.
Originally a Democrat-- he had
served two terms in the Indiana
House of Representatives
as a Democrat--
Debs was a founding member of
several Socialist political
parties.
Socialism was never able to
form a single coherent political
party in this country,
as Socialist leaders--
almost entirely
intellectuals-- endlessly
split over ideological minutia.
There were social Democrats,
anarchists, Communists,
syndicalists, and
many, many more.
Debs joined the Socialist
Party of America in 1901,
a party formed that year from a
merger of the Social Democratic
Party and the
Socialist Labor Party.
He ran for president on
its ticket five times.
In 1912, he received
905,000 votes, fully
6% of the total vote.
In 1920, he won
3.4% of the vote,
although he was in jail
for sedition at the time.
[CHUCKLING]
The Socialist
Party was adamantly
opposed to American
participation in World War I,
and Debs had spoken out in
favor of resisting the draft.
Sentenced to 10 years,
President Warren Harding
commuted the sentence to time
served in December of 1921,
after Debs had served
nearly three years in jail.
After the collapse of the
Czarist regime in Russia
and the subsequent
takeover by the Bolsheviks,
along with this country's
entry into World War I,
the United States experienced
the first of the two
20th century Red Scares.
There were reasons
for these scares.
There were numerous attempts--
some successful-- to bomb
people and property.
The Washington house of Woodrow
Wilson's attorney general,
Mitchell Palmer,
was badly damaged
by a bomb in June, 1919,
although Palmer himself was not
seriously hurt.
And in September, 1920, a
whole wagon-load of dynamite
blew up in front of the
Morgan Bank on Wall Street,
killing 38 and injuring
hundreds, 143 of them severely.
Windows were blown
out for blocks around.
The facade of the Morgan Bank
was scarred by the explosion,
and the bank decided not to
repair the damage, leaving it
as a sort of stigmata
of capitalism.
It's still there, by the way,
a minor Wall Street tourist
attraction.
But the fear generated
by the Red Scare
was far greater than
the actual threat.
Hundreds of aliens
were deported,
including such well-known ones
as Emma Goldman and Alexander
Berkman, who had tried to
assassinate the industrialist
Henry Clay Frick.
By one of those wonderful
coincidences that history
is so full of, the
day he was deported
was the day that Henry Clay
Frick died of natural causes.
And Berkman said, "At least he
left the country before I did."
[LAUGHTER]
While the Socialist
Party never came
anywhere close to winning
a presidential race,
it had electoral success at the
local and congressional levels.
After the election of 1920 put
five Socialists in the New York
State Assembly, they
were summarily suspended
and then expelled.
They all ran in special
elections and were re-elected,
but, again, denied their seats.
The Communist Party
of the United States
was founded in 1919 after
the Russian Revolution,
as a split-off from Debs'
Socialist Party of America.
Unlike Debs' Socialists, it
supported the dictatorship
of the proletariat,
which is to say,
the dictatorship of
self-appointed fiduciaries
for the proletariat.
It was deeply involved in
the American Labor Movement
and, through a variety
of front organizations,
influenced many
prominent people.
During the Great
Depression, membership
grew to 55,000, at least
according to the CPUSA.
But it was, from
the first, largely
funded by and took orders
from the Soviet Union.
Immediately after World War II
broke out in September, 1939,
for instance, the Communist
Party's newspaper,
The Daily Worker, began a
long and frequent series
of editorials, demanding
that this country stay out
of the war.
But on June 23, 1941,
the paper, without even
noting its about-face,
began demanding
the immediate entrance of the
United States into the war.
What had caused it to
change its editorial minds?
Nazi Germany invaded the
Soviet Union on June 22, 1941.
This convinced many that the
Communist Party of the United
States was not a genuine
American political party
but a foreign agent.
Non-Communist Socialism's
political popularity
waned in the 1920s
in this country,
while increasing in Europe.
Both Britain and France elected
Socialist governments in 1924.
But Norman Thomas received
only 2% of the vote
in the election of 1932,
despite the country
being in the depths of
the Great Depression,
while there was widespread
fear that capitalism and even
democracy would not survive.
New Deal programs and especially
the GI Bill of Rights in 1944
proved the death knell
of Socialism in America.
By subsidizing both college
educations and home ownership,
the GI Bill lifted millions
into the middle class
with financial assets,
such as real estate.
In other words, the
proletariat became capitalists.
But at the same time,
so a new Red Scare--
thanks to the onset
of the Cold War--
people like Senator Joseph
McCarthy and the House
Un-American Activities
Committee hounded people
before television
cameras, but found
relatively few
actual Communists,
while ruining many
lives and careers.
Finally, in 1954, Senator
McCarthy overplayed his hand,
was censured by the Senate.
And the second Red Scare
began to fade away.
While Socialism disappeared
as a political force
after World War
II, its last gasp
was probably the
presidential campaign
of Henry Wallace in 1948.
Conservatives have worried
about at what point
the social safety net ends and
latter-day Socialism begins.
The Democratic Party has
moved markedly leftward
in the last few years.
And, today, we are,
once again, hearing
calls from the far left
for Socialist policies,
such as Medicare for All
and egalitarian policies,
such as a punitive wealth tax on
those who have been excessively
successful.
Britain tried this tactic
in the Labout government
of Clement Attlee after World
War II, when the top income tax
rate in Britain was 104%.
[CHUCKLING]
In other words, you were fined
for creating too much wealth.
That goes a long
way to explaining
why Britain's economic recovery
after the war was so sluggish.
Senator Bernie Sanders,
himself a millionaire
who owns three houses,
says that no one should
be worth a billion dollars
and would impose an 8% tax
on the very, very rich,
most of whom, by the way,
made their own fortune.
70% of the Forbes 400 are
self-made men and women.
And no one, of
course, is any poorer
because of the
digital mega fortunes
that have been created
in the last 40 years.
Enriching the rich by
immiserating the poor is
very poor public policy.
Just ask Louis XVI.
Becoming super rich,
as Jeff Bezos has,
by giving everybody a better
and cheaper way to shop
made all of us richer.
Ideologues, like
Bernie Sanders--
he had his honeymoon in the
Soviet Union, please remember--
Stephen Sondheim once
wrote, "I've been to Moscow.
It's very gay, well,
anyway, on the 1st of May."
[LAUGHTER]
These ideologues are often
invincibly ignorant of the most
basic economics.
Not only would a
wealth tax be extremely
hard and expensive
to administer,
it would have
devastating effects
on the entire American economy
and the American population.
If, say, Jeff Bezos had
to pay 8% of his net worth
in taxes every
year, he would have
to sell 8% of his vast
holdings of Amazon stock.
That, of course, would cause
the price of Amazon stock
to drastically decline.
Indeed, just the market's
anticipation of the sale
would cause it to decline,
costing Bezos far more than 8%
of his net worth.
And Amazon stock is held
not just by Jeff Bezos,
but directly or indirectly
by millions of middle-class
Americans in their 401(k)
accounts, IRAs, pension funds,
and annuity accounts.
About 2/3 of
corporate stock today
is held not by plutocrats
but by ordinary Americans.
Multiply Jeff Bezos'
woes under a wealth
tax by those of the other 620
billionaires in the country
today, and you would have
a stock market crash that
would be worse than 1929.
So a wealth tax, while
sticking it to the Forbes 400,
would also stick to
just about everyone
in this room, not to mention
Hillsdale College's endowment
fund.
I expect that these policies
will get exactly nowhere.
The wealth tax is, after
all, almost certainly
unconstitutional, as
it is a direct tax that
could not be apportioned
among the states
according to population.
You could also make a good case
that it is a bill of attainder.
After all, Forbes
magazine will supply you
with a list of the 621
billionaires in this country.
The overwhelming
majority of Americans
celebrate capitalist
success, not
decry it like Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren,
and do not want to kill
the capitalist goose that
has laid so very many golden
eggs for so many people.
They understand instinctively,
thanks to those risk-taking
entrepreneurial genes they
inherited, that Socialism--
to borrow a phrase
from George Orwell--
is an "idea so stupid
that only an intellectual
could believe it."
[LAUGHTER]
The United States is still very
stony ground for Socialism.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you, Mr. Gordon.
We now have time for some
Q&A. If you have a question,
please make your way to the
microphone in the aisle.
AUDIENCE: Yes, sir.
The one thing you brought
up, or at least touched
on tangentially, was
income inequality.
How do you feel about the
concept of the cooperative?
Does that give capitalism
a bit of a safety valve?
I know it works.
I mean, in a small sense,
it's part of our economy,
cooperative structures.
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
You know, a corporation
is a cooperative structure.
People come together
under a defined set
of rules in hopes of making more
money collectively than they
could make individually.
I mean, so there's nothing
wrong with cooperative ventures.
And if the people who are in
that want to do it that way,
that's fine.
But the income
inequality, every time
you have serious
new technology, you
have a sudden inflorescene
of new fortunes
that are larger than
the old ones were.
I mean, in 1827, a young
British writer coined
the word "millionaire"
in order to describe,
not the old aristocracy whose
wealth was based on land,
but the new industrialists,
who were much richer,
usually in terms of cash.
The aristocrats are often
cash poor or land poor,
as they call it.
And by the way,
that young writer
went on to another profession.
His name was Benjamin Disraeli.
[CHUCKLING]
It happened again in
the late 19th century
with railroads and
automobiles and what have you.
And now it is happening with
digital technology, fortunes
that were simply inconceivable
even 40 years ago.
I mean, 1982 was the first
year of the Forbes 400,
and you needed $82
million to make the list.
And the richest
guy was a guy named
Ludwig, who nobody remembers
anymore, who was worth,
I think, it was $2.1 billion.
Today, you need $2.1 billion
to get onto the Forbes list.
There are about 200
American billionaires not
rich enough to make that list.
Now, nobody's gotten poorer
because of these new fortunes.
This is wealth that was created.
It wasn't taken.
I mean, Elizabeth
Warren thinks capitalism
is a zero-sum game like
poker, where for every winner,
you have to have a loser.
We are all winners.
Anybody who's ever bought
something from Amazon
or used Twitter or, you know,
found out where the hell
you were through the GPS on your
cell phone, we are all winners.
There's no losers, which I
wish people who just get that
through their heads.
I think they actually understand
it, but they just politically--
you know, politicians
lie like rugs.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, really
kind of two questions.
One quick one-- when
the polls mention
people between the
ages of 18 and 25, 50%
say they would like to live
in a Socialist country.
Do they really understand
what Socialist means?
Do they understand
that the government is
the employer, is controlling?
Are they just
economically illiterate?
And, secondly, could you
comment on capitalism in China?
JOHN STEELE GORDON: OK.
I think an awful lot of
those 18 to 24-year-olds
went to propaganda mills
masquerading as universities.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
They just-- obviously, they
don't understand economics.
They don't understand
human nature.
I mean, that's why
Socialism can't work because
of human nature, because
we are self-interested,
and we pursue our
self interests.
And you can't-- people
can't stop doing that.
And, you know, a
lot of people think
that self-interest is greed.
No, it's not.
I mean, Mother Teresa
was self-interested.
And what made her happy
was spending her life
in the slums of Calcutta.
What made Jeff Bezos happy
was making $160 billion.
[CHUCKLING]
And as for capitalism
in China, China
is a very weird
hybrid at this moment.
It is capitalist in some ways.
But, of course, it is a
complete tyranny in others.
And there's still huge state
enterprises, most of which
are very inefficient, as
state enterprises tend to be.
And they keep getting bucked
up by the Chinese government.
I don't think that's a stable
system in the long run.
And China, you
know, remember, you
can't trust Chinese statistics.
They make them up, just
like the Soviet Union did.
There's a lot of unrest
that you don't hear about
because if reporters report it,
they suddenly find themselves
no longer in China.
But only about, I think it's
65% of the Chinese population is
Han Chinese.
The rest are all Uyghurs
out in Xinjiang, Manchus
up in Manchuria.
There's all kinds of
ethnic minorities in China,
and many of them are not happy.
Now, China has got firm control.
I mean, they're not going to
go gentle into that good night,
I promise you.
But I don't think,
in the long term,
you can have this capitalist
tyranny sustained,
but we will see.
AUDIENCE: My question relates
to the last gentleman.
You mentioned that
Socialism so far
has had a stony ground
in the United States.
With the plurality
of millennials
embracing Socialism or
appearing to embrace Socialism,
do you find that a little
bit of an alarming statistic?
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
Yeah, it's very alarming.
But I think, once they get
out into the real world,
they'll probably
have to wise up.
I mean, show me a
Socialist economy
that has been successful.
There aren't any.
So why should we have
a Socialist economy
here when we've had the
most success economy
in the history of the world?
So let's get rid of
that idea that works
and get one that has a proven
track record of failure?
It's just-- the mind boggles.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
I was wondering, you
mentioned earlier
that there was an experiment on
the East Coast of a Socialist,
like a community that
did work, and that
still survived for 50 years.
Why is that?
JOHN STEELE GORDON: Well,
it's a very small community,
and people are free
to come and go.
And so people, they try it
out for a couple of years,
and then they move on,
and other people move in.
And I think it's not a tyranny.
People are free to come and go.
They're not forced to be there.
And they can go outside it
and earn money on the outside.
I mean, they're free
people, who choose
to live in this
very small community
and do things together.
And I think there's 60, 70
people who live on that place.
And that small a group can do
very well, just like, you know,
hunter-gatherer groups in the
Paleolithic did very well.
And potentially, it was
the same kind of system.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Can you comment on our
fiat currency and its perceived
stability in our
capitalistic economy?
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
Would you say that again?
AUDIENCE: Can you comment on
our fiat currency's stability
and how you think
that might impact
our capitalistic economy?
JOHN STEELE GORDON: OK.
Well, every country in the
world now has fiat currencies.
And what keeps them honest is
the currency-trading market,
which trades around
$5 trillion a day.
And in the early 1980s,
the president of France,
Francois Mitterrand,
tried a Socialist agenda.
He nationalized the French
banks and on and on and on.
The currency market tanked,
the French currency,
to the point where
Mitterrand had
no alternative but to back off.
And that's what-- we
got rid of inflation.
In the 1970s, inflation
roared in this country.
In 1980, the prime rate was
20%, which is really awesome.
But then the currency
market got big enough.
It got globalized enough so
it can act as a single unit
basically.
And that's what
keeps politicians
from printing too
much of the stuff.
And occasionally, there are
countries like Argentina, which
does it over and
over and over again,
and then they keep
reelecting Peronistas
over and over and over again.
It's really-- Argentina
is a wonderful country,
but their politics
is just bizarre.
It makes French
politics look good.
[LAUGHTER]
I think our money's under
control at the moment.
And we also have a--
if Congress could
print money, then we'd
be in serious trouble.
But they can't.
Only the Fed can do that.
That's one that
Hamilton said, you know,
don't let politicians
anywhere near
the power of printing money.
AUDIENCE: One of the most
effective enemies of capitalism
are the capitalists themselves.
Bill Gates is giving
away his money
by the billions, trying to buy
himself a Mother Teresa halo.
Why are they doing that?
What is their view of
morality that they consider--
Mother Teresa would
help the few people out
of the gutter better
than the people
that [INAUDIBLE] the gutter.
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
Herbert Hoover famously
said that the trouble with
capitalism is capitalists.
And he's right because
capitalists are all
too happy-- or many of them
are-- to become rent-seekers
if they can get away with it.
And in this time in this world,
they can very frequently.
The government gives them
special little fiddles
on the side.
But the tax code is corrupt
from page one to page 56,000.
And half of it is literally
little quiet fiddles
to people who make big
political contributions.
But I'm afraid, again,
that's human nature, too.
If you can get a cheap buck,
you're going to take it.
And who can blame them?
So it just-- you know,
human, [STUTTERS],,
we are not angels, as
James Madison so astutely
pointed out.
And that's true of capitalists,
and it's true of politicians,
and it's true of
university professors, so--
even the occasional speaker.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So according to the
World Health Care Organization,
the American health
care is around,
I think, 36th on the list,
whereas the French health
care and Canadian
health care are
in front of the American ones.
So I was wondering, why do you
think socialized health cares
like theirs can be
higher up on that list
than the American one,
if they should be more
innovative and more functional?
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
There's two things here.
One is statistics.
In many European
countries, a baby
that dies very
shortly after birth
is listed as a stillbirth,
whereas in this country,
if a baby is born
struggling, they
move Heaven and Earth
to keep it alive.
And if they lose it,
it's an infant mortality.
So we have a higher
infant mortality rate
than Britain and France
and other countries do.
But that's a statistical thing.
The other thing is the
American health care
system is a complete mess.
I mean, it's the best
system in the world
in terms of its ability
to cure the incurable.
But economically,
it is terrible.
I mean, there is no
price transparency
in the United States.
I mean, you go to a hospital and
say, I need my knee replaced.
How much would you charge?
They won't tell you.
And then you get this
bill that's this thick,
and one aspirin tablet,
$2.50, and what have you.
And Donald Trump is actually
trying to get them to do this.
And both the insurance
companies and the hospitals
are fighting tooth and
nail to prevent it.
If they were forced to post
their prices everywhere,
and so every
hospital had to say,
we'll do a knee transplant
for x, now, immediately,
what would happen?
AUDIENCE: Competition.
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
The competition
would force people to
lower their prices.
And we could drain
at least $2 trillion
a year out of
American health care,
simply by making them
post their prices.
But the American
Medical Association,
the American
Hospital Association
are extremely potent
lobbies in Washington.
But that would go a long
way to solving health care.
We have too many hospitals
in this country, very hard
politically to close them.
What we need is more
specialty hospitals,
like Memorial Sloan Kettering
in New York, the great cancer
hospital, and then
urgent care places.
And then small towns need
maybe small hospitals.
And if somebody is really
sick, then they ship them off
to a major metropolitan area.
But we have many, many,
too many hospital beds
at the moment, which
is also very expensive.
AUDIENCE: John, thank
you for your talk.
One thing I would
recommend to everybody
is they read his books, starting
with Hamilton's Blessing.
It is a fantastic work.
As for a question, my question
has to do with inflation.
How come we don't have
it, even though we've
printed so much money?
Is it because of our
incredible productivity?
Or is it bad data, that
we're not actually seeing
it being reported correctly?
What do you think?
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
Well, one reason
is the digitalization
of the economy,
as enormous efficiencies
are built into that.
I mean, so it's--
as I say, Amazon--
again, I'm always
talking about Amazon,
I only go there two or
three times a week--
[LAUGHTER]
They're able to sell
things at a much lower cost
than brick-and-mortar
because they
have such enormous
economies of scale.
And Walmart, too, Walmart,
its economic power's
so that it can force its
suppliers to really cut things
to the bone.
And so that's what, I think,
has kept inflation under check
in the last, this revolution
that we've been undergoing
for the last 30-odd years.
AUDIENCE: I haven't understood
this because the same car
I bought--
AUDIENCE: Sorry, sir, can
you use the microphone?
AUDIENCE: The same car--
AUDIENCE: Use the
microphone, sir.
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
Yeah, use the mic.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
The very same car
I bought in Charleston,
West Virginia, 22 years ago
is 2 and 1/2 times the cost now.
JOHN STEELE GORDON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that's
inflation, isn't it?
JOHN STEELE GORDON: No, you
have a much better car today.
AUDIENCE: Well, no, I
mean, how is it any better?
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
Well, they last
a lot longer than they used to.
They have all kinds of
wonderful gadgets, like GPS.
I noticed when I got
in the car this morning
to get to the
airport, and the car,
it automatically changed the
clock to Daylight Saving Time.
And I thought, that's
really neat because I never
remember to do that.
And I mean, cars are pretty
mature technology basically.
But I bought my first
computer in 1986.
It had a 12-inch black and
white cathode ray monitor, a dot
matrix printer, which
was terribly noisy
and only did one typeface.
I had 8 mgs of RAM and
20-megabyte hard drive,
which I thought in 1986,
that was pretty sexy.
In 2019 terms, in dollars,
it cost around $7,000.
Today, I have a 24-inch high
def, flat screen, full color
monitor.
I have an inkjet printer.
I have 8 gigabytes of RAM, and
I have a terabyte of hard drive
that's 50,000 times as big as
my first hard drive 30-odd years
ago.
And, of course, the whole
system cost around $1,200.
So that's a technology
that's rapidly advancing,
and so the prices are
rapidly collapsing,
whereas automobiles are--
they've been around
since 1896 when--
who was it-- Mercedes--
Mercedes was the daughter.
I forget the man's name who
invented the carburetor, which
was the last little gizmo
needed to make the car work.
Carburetors, of course,
have long disappeared.
So I think that's
mostly it is we just
get better and cheaper
in making these things,
and they're better things, too.
I mean, it used to be a car
that lasted 100,000 miles, even
if you took good care
of it, that was good.
Now, 200,000 miles is,
by no means, unheard of.
SPEAKER: We have time--
we have time for
one more question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm
curious if you identify
any inconsistency
or incongruence
between the right's simultaneous
rejection of Socialism
or the far left with their
embrace of protectionist
policies at the same time,
because a lot of people
might classify those as
the type of rent-seeking
that you were just
mentioning a few minutes ago.
JOHN STEELE GORDON:
All manufacturers
think that their suppliers
should be highly competitive,
but their customers
should have no choices.
[LAUGHTER]
Again, welcome to human nature.
I mean, so protection is
a bad idea just of itself.
But there-- you're always
going to have tariffs
because, for some
reason, sometimes
we have strategic reasons
for having tariffs.
I mean, we have to
have an airplane
industry in this country.
You can't be a great power
without an airplane industry.
But it also-- you can use
it as a political tactic,
as Trump is using
against China right now.
But high tariffs never work.
Well, they-- because,
again, a tariff is a tax,
so it drives up the
price for everybody else.
And it allows manufacturers
in this country
to be less efficient.
When they're hidden
behind tariff walls,
they don't have to work hard.
And nobody works any
harder than they have
to to accomplish their goals.
You know, lions don't chase
the fast zebras to gets supper.
[LAUGHTER]
They chase the slow ones,
who taste just as good.
[LAUGHTER]
I have it on the best authority.
[CHUCKLES]
All right.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]